new trailer for glass so I got to talk
about it because I want to talk about it
I feel like I'm gonna see glass before I
actually do my top 10 anticipated movies
in 2019 so if that happens just know if
this is one of my top 10 anticipated
movies for 2019 all I know is there are
worse things to wake up to first thing I
noticed and really liked in this trailer
is it has the unbreakable theme the
theme that when I heard and split I was
like that's a little lazy reusing a
theme from one of his other movies give
it a few seconds I was like oh [ __ ] it's
the sequel I've wanted for a very long
time or spin-off whatever but that
really brings in the tone also it's a
great thing but from the trailer I
pretty much know but I already figured I
knew and that is Elijah price breaks out
of his confinement using the help of
Kevin or the beast and from there he's
gonna test David done he's gonna put him
in a situation where it's like hey you
got to do this and it looks like
possibly if he does do this then people
are gonna know that they exist which
opens up the possibilities of sequels
arge universe I don't require sequels or
spin-offs past this I've just wanted
this movie for a very long time we'll
see how this goes so playing on the
theme of comic books like unbreakable it
was a realistic if not different spin on
a comic book universe or a comic book
world you see that in here with Elijah
price just kind of being in a state of
apathy he's just really depressed kind
of reminded me of the Joker and the Dark
Knight Returns he hasn't done anything
he's just been sitting there since
Batman's been gone he's had nothing to
do he hasn't been able to interact with
his opposite he has no purpose
it looks like Elijah price is kind of in
the same state here he's all art I
haven't seen David done in almost 20
years I'm depressed the walls are
closing in so be sure to go to chat
therapy roulette slash Elijah to give me
200 bucks a head yeah Jeff therapy
roulette is not responsible for any bus
driver sign spinner or party clown who
may be posing as a therapist but he will
find purpose and motivation to do the
next thing
I love how Elijah prices mom is a mom
tomato master what a mom thing does that
sure he committed multiple acts of
terrorism killing hundreds of people but
look at all he's accomplished he's so
smart I guess you could say someone's
too smart for someone else without
actually condoning what they do it just
seems like such a supportive bomb thing
to say maybe laughs that's my favorite
part of the trailer right there I want
to do that now go up to random people so
if you find a random video of me being
tased on YouTube just know that I was
quoting glass I do feel like with this
trailer we pretty much know that gist of
the movie so I hope the trailer didn't
show too much of the movie but knowing
Shyamalan it probably didn't there's
gotta be more to it there's gotta be
that twist at the end
I hope the twist is an actual like oh my
god
inspiring kind of ending and not just
there are more now there are more super
people cuz I kind of figured it's gonna
happen anyway because the trailers have
told me that I guess that's what I like
about unbreakable in this glass movie is
that I just love Elijah price mr. glass
so much like David Duncan [ __ ] end
him with one punch that'd be it even
when they were in that room you could
just break out of those chains and beat
his ass to death but he doesn't mr.
glass is such a threat but he's not a
physical threat he's the arch enemy who
now has a soldier villain and that's
just that's gonna be a good test trailer
for glass I really like it I don't want
to see any more trailers for glass I
just want to see glass in January so let
this be the last regardless the trailer
for glass have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]